dass jetzt eine ja wirklich unglaubliche
geschichte die story von thomas heller
aus köthen was hat dieser mann für ein
glück eine küche hat er gesucht bei ebay
eine günstige gebrauchte küche und die
hat er dann auch gefunden aber eben
nicht nur das unglaublich ja in dieser
gebrauchten günstigen billigen küche
waren versteckt dass hier
150000 euro 150000 euro versteckt im
kühlschrank im küchenschrank jetzt ist
er bei uns weil wir live thomas eller
herzlich willkommen heller sie haben für
eine kinder- und jugendwohngruppe dieser
alte diese gebrauchten küche gekauft für
den sportpreis 240 euro ich glaube die
sollte erst 300 euro kosten oder so sie
haben dann noch mal ein bisschen runter
gehandelt also noch günstiger und dann
stecken da
150000 euro plötzlich drin beschreiben
sie mal den moment als sie all diese
kohle im küchenschrank gefunden haben
hallo erst mal wird sie natürlich ist
das unheimlich viel geld aber ich habe
nie
bewusst wie viel geld ist ist weil die
zwei kassetten nur eine kassette
offenbar und die zweite dann auch erst
von der polizei bei der polizei ohne
meine bei seien geöffnet ich kannte die
summe nie
bekannt wort die so oft eine kassette
und oben lang einen briefumschlag und da
haben mich 100 euro angeschaut und da
wusste ich das ist nicht mein geld und
das gehört jemand an man muss aber
trotzdem sagen sie sind ja wohl
ehrlichste mann deutschlands denn der
ein oder andere oder die ein oder andere
hätten vielleicht gesagt gut jackpot ist
ja jetzt meine küche her mit dem geld
sie aber sie behalten das geld nicht
ja es ist vielleicht sogar noch
schlimmer ich hatte angst dass ich mich
strafbar gemacht habe indem ich etwas
mitgenommen was mir gar nicht gehört
also ist das überhaupt keinen zweifel
aufgekommen dass mir das geld gehört ja
also ich gehe immer davon aus egal was
da drin ist es gehört nämlich ich hatte
eine hoffnung es ist ein ausweis dass
ich das kinder zurückgeben kann aber es
war
doch mal ganz kurz also zumindest den
moment ist es ehrt sie ganz wahnsinnig
dass sie sofort gesagt haben das ist
nicht meins das müsste vor zurückgeben
aber gab sich den moment wo ganz
irgendwie malediven für immer durch den
kopf ging großer autos irgendwas hatten
sie nicht diesen moment
im nachhinein kann man nur spekulieren
was man bis zu vier geld hätte alles
sich für träume erfüllen können aber
tatsächlich war es eher so dass es eine
belastung war ich ein schlechtes
gewissen und tatsächlich druck auf den
brustkorb hatte weil ich eine
verantwortung für geld von jemand anders
hatte die ich gar nicht wollte
wem gehört denn jetzt das geld wissen
sie dass und bekommen sie denn
wenigstens für ihre ehrlichkeit im
finderlohn oder so
die polizei hat mir mitgeteilt dass es
eine seniorin gehört die 91 jahre alt
sein soll ich hatte gestern nachmittag
einen anruf von jemandem der sich als
enkel dieser
frau ausgabe und gesagt sie zieht jetzt
aus ihrem krieger hey music zurzeit
untergebracht ist in eine neue wohnung
und er wird sich dann hinterher mit der
oma ein jahr melden um die modalitäten
des finderlohns auszumachen die oma
möchte wahrscheinlich meine in richtung
selbst besuchen und druckt das geld über
diesen kindern übergeben ja und für die
kinder und jugendlichen wäre es auf
jeden fall gut angelegt dort herzlichen
dank für das gespräch mit ihnen herr
heller und dafür dass sie so wahnsinnig
ehrlich waren dank tolle geschichte
denken